I just can't imagine this room without
you so don't don't think about millions
of fans of chrono minds were blindsided
last night when it became clear that
shemar Moore was finished and we were
the only ones today to talk with him
about his surprise exit from the show
that he has called home for nearly a
decade last night was not goodbye Derek
didn't die so anything's possible and
I'm not I'm not leaving to go be a big
star and try to make a lot of money
right now I'm leaving just to take a
breath and you know and just just things
I want to do I want to travel I want to
walk my dogs more he's such a good guy
and Shamar has earned a break after 11
seasons on the show and it started last
night at what sounds like a crazy
afterparty
yeah a rough night last yeah yeah I did
I'm not gonna lie I'm a stayed up a
little late celebrating partying with
mom friends um and celebrating this
transition this this this elevator
closing chapter 11 years and it's a it's
a really proud feeling cried a little
bit you know gee but but uh still it's
still looking good I don't know about
this morning on the Starbucks is okay
yeah yeah yeah mellow raspy this is my
sexy morning place his mom is thrilled
because part of the reason Shamar is
stepping away from Criminal Minds is to
have time to find a special lady I want
to get married I wanna oh that little
pitter-patter in your heart I wanna have
little Rugrats running around going
daddy daddy daddy cuz right now like my
kids my two Bulldogs but it's at some
point I'd like the real thing my mother
is on me for years she's gonna be the
oldest grandmother in the world if I
don't hurry up
I kind of feel like I'm not pushing
reset but I'm reinventing myself and
incoming brand-new just a just to feel
another layer of the onion off and see
see see what's there I think a lot of
ladies would like to see you peel that
layer of onion and again and again until
there's you know so ladies line up this
45 year old star is ready to settle down
and keep promises this isn't the end of
baby girl are we gonna cure baby girl
again oh yeah oh yeah baby girl so I've
been saying baby girl since I was about
10 years old so no baby girl nation in
going anywhere but I'm like when I come
back I'm gonna come back on sways and
excited and ready to perform